>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Nancy Groce: Hello.
I'm Nance Groce.
I'm a folklorist at the American
Folklife Center here at the Library
of Congress and I'd like to welcome
you to our latest presentation
in an ongoing Benjamin
A Botkin Lecture Series.
The Botkin series allows
us to highlight the work
of leading scholars in the
disciplines of folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral history
and cultural heritage while
enhancing the collections here
at the American Folklife Center.
For this center and the Library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of our acquisitions activities.
Each lecture is videotaped
and becomes part
of the permanent collections
here at this center.
In addition, the lectures
are later posted as webcast
on the Library's website where
they'll be available for viewing
to internet patrons
throughout the world.
So if you haven't already done
so, now would be an excellent time
to shut off any electronic devices
that you are carrying with you.
Today, I'm delighted to
welcome Samuel Torjman Thomas,
a performer in ethnomusicologist
who holds degrees
from the Berkley College of Music
in Jazz Composition and Performance,
a Master's from CUNY/Brooklyn
College
and who recently finished
a PhD in Ethnomusicology
and the City University of New York.
Samuel is currently teaching at
CUNY's John Jay and Hunter Colleges
and he's really a multifaceted
person.
He's a performer, he's a woodwind
specialist and he plays sax, ney,
clarinet, flute and
I'm sure other things.
You're a percussionist.
You're a composer and
also a vocalist.
As an ethnomusicologist,
his research focuses
on North African musical traditions,
Arab music, Jewish music,
and also jazz, rock and
American popular music.
Thomas is a founder and leader of
Asefa, I'm pronouncing it right,
Asefa, a New York based ensemble
devoted to contemporary approaches
to composition, improvisation
and fusion drawn from Sephardic,
North African and jazz traditions.
He's also the Executive Director
of JATM, the Jewish Awareness
Through Music, an applied
ethnomusicology organization focused
on cultural exchange through music.
And I understand some of your
ancestors came from Morocco, Sam,
so as most of you here
know Morocco has one
of the world's most
complex musical soundscapes.
Moroccan music has always had
a fascination for him and here
at the Library of Congress
at the American Folklife
Center we also have--
are particularly proud to have
some very important collections
of Moroccan music including
the fieldwork recordings
of Paul Bowles and
Henrietta Yurchenco.
So, we get forms of an important
facet of our collection here
at the American Folklife Center.
I just want to take a
moment to thank the Library
of Congress' Hebrew Language
Table and especially Gail Shirazi
for co-sponsoring today's
Botkin lecture as well
as acknowledging the
cooperation and support
of the Washington Jewish Music
Festival, which is in the midst
of its 17th Annual
Jewish Music Festival.
And I believe the performers you'll
see here today will be performing
this evening.
I'd also like to welcome, I'm not
sure he's here yet, Mr. Fouad Arif
who is with, the Head of the
Moroccan official news agency,
Maghreb Arabe Press and also
Charles Jahant, who will be coming,
who will be honoring
us with their presence.
Today, Dr. Thomas will be
speaking on the musical soundscapes
of Morocco from Africa to America.
Please join me in making
him welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Samuel Thomas: Thank you Nancy,
thank you Gail and the Library.
And welcome.
Good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen how are you?
Good, excellent.
So I'm intending with this lecture
to give a bit of a whirlwind tour
of Morocco in terms of its
background and its foundations
and especially in the idea
of how the circulation
of musical expression has gone
beyond the borders of Morocco
and especially here in America.
My research, which we'll get
to a little bit more as well,
deals most specifically with the
Moroccan Jewish community in America
but beyond that of course with the
Moroccan community in general --
both my research work and as a
performer encapsulates much more.
So we'll touch on that as well.
And, of course, I would be remiss
if I didn't mention these really
interesting-looking instruments
up here and the need to share those
with you at some point as well.
And then if you like what you hear
and there will be more tonight here
in DC, which you can come and
experience an entire concert,
so with no further ado:
"The Musical Soundscapes
of Morocco from Africa to America."
First of all, one of the most
important points that I would make
about Morocco and its history
is the inherent diversity
in the country itself.
How many of you have
been to Morocco?
OK. So, you know, you know
what I'm talking about already.
But for everybody to be on the
same page let us do a little bit
of a background here that
the inherent diversity
of Morocco is certainly one
of the most valuable elements
of Moroccan society and perhaps
one of the most promising elements
for humanity in general, if I
may wax a little bit polemical
for a moment.
But the diversity there in
terms of ethnic diversity,
there are several languages
that are spoken in Morocco,
the Amazigh dialect of the
popularly known Berber community,
which is the native North
Africans; there's Arabic, of course,
and that being a Maghrebi or
North African dialect that Arabic:
there's Hebrew; and, of course,
there's French and there's Spanish.
So there's quite a lot of
linguistic diversity going
on in Morocco itself.
And, of course, with all
of that linguistic diversity
comes also a diversity in religion
and even in racial background.
So as I mentioned before already
we have the North African Native
community, but we have
the Arabic community
which is the Arab communities
been there already for several,
several centuries since the
early expansion of Islam
across North Africa to the West.
And then the Jewish community dates
back 2000 years, the destruction
of the Second Temple
in Jerusalem, well,
destruction of the First Temple
actually began the Jewish Diaspora
as we know it, but by the Second
Temple certainly Jews are traveling
further afield and ending up in many
different parts of the Roman world
and Morocco itself was
part of that constellation.
So, that is really
very deeply inherent.
We also have the Sub-Saharan African
community, the Gnaoua community
in Morocco brought across
the Saharan Arab slave trade
and certainly infusing a large West
African presence in the county.
What we'll get to, we'll get to
a little bit more in a moment.
So, just a couple photos to
kind of represent this idea.
This is a Quran, picture of
a Quran written in Morocco.
This is a collection of Torah
scrolls in the Aron or the cabinet
of a Moroccan synagogue and
they are uniquely Moroccan
and that they are standing
up in these kind
of very ornate round
encasings with scarves
on them and things like that.
And then we have here the Hamsa,
which is a very prominent symbol
throughout the Middle Eastern world.
But, and if you notice, the
writing on it is actually Amazigh,
which is the Berber dialect.
So, we have this kind
of juxtaposition
of this diversity just
everywhere in Moroccan society.
Certainly, we must
also take into account
that there's regional
diversity in Morocco.
Certainly there are
villages and there are cities
and there are coastal
areas and inland areas.
So, you know, that has an effect too
on the culture of Morocco overall.
And topographically, too, we
have quite a diversity going on.
We have several mountain ranges--
some of you have probably traveled
through the Atlas perhaps even
the Rift Mountains in the north.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>>Samuel Thomas: Yup, and we
have the valley areas and we have
of course the edge
of the Sahara Desert.
All of these different
zones juxtaposition
in one relatively small land area.
So, this is kind of
at a fundamental core
of Moroccan diversity, I would say.
To move on, you can see over here
the reason I've included this map is
to talk a bit about Morocco as a
conduit point between East and West,
because Moroccan history--
and this is I point
out to the population flows.
Moroccan history being on the
cusp of North Africa there,
on the farthest western side, has
seen people traveling through it
as kind of a nexus point and I think
that's very fundamental as well
to Moroccan culture--
to the development of Moroccan
culture over the centuries.
The notion of Morocco as isolated
from the Iberian Peninsula
is relatively recent.
Morocco would-- The flows between
people across the Iberian Peninsula,
I mean, across the
Strait of Gibraltar
into the Iberian Peninsula is
very common in earlier centuries.
In fact, if anybody is up
on Andalus history, right,
the founding of the Andalusian
Caliphate in Cordoba was
with the help of Berber mercenary
armies, Amazigh armies from Morocco.
In fact, Gibraltar is titled after
the general who led these armies,
Tariq ibn Ziyad, and that's why
it's called Jabal Tariq the Mount
of Tariq, Gibraltar.
Furthermore, as we continue
into later centuries we certainly
have empires actually being
expressed centered in Morocco
and expressed across the Strait
of Gibraltar, the Al Mourabitoun and
the Al Muwahhidun are both centered
in Morocco, but expressing
their power northward.
So, point being that this is kind
of a nexus point and has been
for a long time for a lot of
diversity to travel through.
And, of course, with that is going
to come a diversity in
cultural expressions.
So to turn now to the diversity
in my area of interest with--
in terms of musical expression would
be the Moroccan musical cultures,
right?
So, what do I mean by Arab, Amazigh,
Andalusi, Gnaoua musical cultures?
So, included in this would be, well,
with the Arab musical cultures would
be the kinds of things developed
in the classical style
of music centered
around Arabic composition both in
terms of the poetry and in terms
of the music itself;
systems of music.
So, this would be developing
in Abbasid,
Baghdad finding its way westward
and be developing in Andalus
and finding its way southward.
To this very day the Arab classical
music tradition in Morocco,
al-Ala al-Andalusia, is
markedly different from the
"Arab classical styles"
that are in Algeria
and Tunisia further to the east.
The Ottoman Empire stopped
at the doorstep of Morocco.
So, the patrimony
of the Andalusian-Moroccan classical
music sphere has been kept more
intact in Morocco.
So, this is expressed in the
modes, the musical modes,
in the rhythmic modes,
certainly in the song texts
and in the melodies themselves.
So, that I would-- I classify
there under the Arab styles.
Amazigh styles would be the
again the native communities
that primarily centered outside
the cities in the villages
or in the smaller towns and there
you have different instruments,
different approaches
to melody making,
certainly different
languages, different texts,
and even some different-- entirely
different performance contexts.
And there is some overlap there
which without getting too technical
I don't think this lecture is
to be super, super technical so
I'm not going to get into the taqs
and the dooms in terms
of the rhythmic cycles,
but you can see a lot
of that happen.
So, the Andalusi, as I remark
before, this connection
to Andalusian music and
the patrimony of that
and then the Gnaoua music as well
which is this Sub-Saharan music
that is been present in
Morocco now for centuries.
Anybody here had been to
Jemaa el-Fnaa in Marrakech?
Yes. So did you have
a chance to dance
with any Gnaoua musicians there?
They usually like to get
you involved, you know.
Huh?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>>Samuel Those: Yes you will.
OK, good. You will.
Excellent.
And after this, you know, you'll
be ready to jump right in, good.
So, in terms of musical systems, and
this where I will get a little bit,
I guess, technical for
us a bit, is the rhythm,
melody and language elements.
Rhythmically speaking,
Moroccan music pretty much
across the board does share
these foundations and kind
of a 12-ish beat rhythmic
cycle and some breakup of this
and we hear this in
the Gnaoua music,
we hear it in the Amazigh community,
and in the Arab music cycles.
How it is expressed in terms
of degrees of sophistication
or different variations
and stuff like that depends
on the music and the community.
But the rhythm for the most part
is quite driving, quite cyclical
and quite-- what's the
word I'm looking for here--
infectious I think, yeah.
So, if you find yourself
looking for a groove
and finding yourself
tapping along then
that I think is just about right.
So, definitely aim for that.
In terms of melody-making, there
are different modes for melody.
So we have, you know, in the West,
in Western classical styles
we have modes typically based
around-welcome-- and typically
based around like a harmonic system.
So, for instance, you know,
the Do-Re-Mi-Fa-So-La-Ti-Do.
So we have this and then we have
another mode built upon that
but it's all harmonically
driven, right?
Whereas, in Moroccan music
it's all melodically driven,
so that the melody takes absolute
precedence there really is no
harmony per se to play chords
behind it or something like that.
It's really about knowing
the melodies.
Now the melodies do come
out of certain modes
like a Do-Re-Mi-Fa-So-La-Ti-Do
kind of thing,
but you could have two modes
that have the exact same notes
but different notes
are emphasized, right?
So, you could emphasize
Do-RE-Mi-Fa-So, that's one,
or it could be
Do-Re-Mi-FA-So-Fa-Mi-Re-Do.
And that's a different setup.
So how the notes are emphasized
makes big difference in terms
of the system, the
systemizing of the melody.
Then, in terms of melody-making
the--
it's all melodically driven music so
that the melodies can be repetitive
and then changing to another melody
quite making a stark contrast
or the melodies can be more
complex in the classical tradition.
And the way that musicians
are really trained are
to really learn these melodies
internally to the degree
that you can begin to play
around these melodies.
And what happens out of that is very
different from the Western context.
So, I mean, I'm putting this in
relief to the Western context
but the Western classical style
where the harmony is driving a lot
of this and you have a
harmonic motion or, you know,
like the sonata form for instance
where you have a change of pitch
in fact at another point in the
movement is all harmonically driven.
In this music being that it's all
melodically driven there are moments
of harmony.
So the question is, well, what
are these moments of harmony
and how are they determined, right?
If they're not determined
in advance,
then how are they determined?
They are determined
in a heterophonic way.
So, for those of you that may
not be familiar with that term,
heterophony is when you have a
classroom of kids trying to sing
"Mary Had a Little
Lamb" together, OK?
Or, if we all try to
sing, I don't know,
"Stars Spangled Banner"
together, right now,
I think we would experience
some heterophony.
And that just means that we end up--
we all know the melody but we end
up sort of expressing it timewise
a little different and we end
up getting these variations
that happen and so, you know,
you move on to the next note at a
different time than you do and out
of that creates harmony of course.
And that harmony then becomes
like an emergent quality rather
than a predetermined quality.
So, listening to Moroccan
music and understanding it
that way I think is
a very important key.
So that is the melodic approach.
Language systems.
Well, there are certainly styles
where the language is the higher
level composition in terms
of the poetry and the expression
of ideas of religious significance
such as, you know, texts
taken directly from the Quran
or in Hebrew the poets often
would be incorporating segments
from the Torah or from
the Tanakh and weaving
that together with other ideas.
So, that's kind of like I
would say a high register.
Then you have a more colloquial
style language expression
that is typically in Arabic
and then you have, of course,
songs in Amazigh, as
I mentioned before.
You have songs that are even mixing.
And one important category to point
out would be the Judeo-Español songs
that are a unique dialect
in Morocco.
So the Jews that were
part of the Expulsion,
the migration from the Expulsion
of Spain in 1492, many of which,
of course, settled in Morocco
because of its proximity to Iberia,
to Spain, were bringing a
version of Spanish, right?
And that version of Spanish
would be mixed with Hebrew words
and as it would get into
Morocco it would be even mixed
with Hebrew words and even sometimes
Arabic words and you would have
out of this then a unique dialect
that would develop over centuries
in contradistinction, let's
say, from that which developed
by the Sephardic Jews in
Turkey, or in Amsterdam.
So that is part of
the language, too.
And, well, I won't have time to
play you all the stuff I'd love
to play you today, but there are
some really interesting pieces
that combined, you know, this
diversity within the music
that you can really hear.
The melodic stuff I'm talking about
mixed with the language of Haketia
which is the Judeo-Español dialect.
So, in sum, what I'm getting
to is that Morocco's diversity,
its inherent diversity in its
topography, in its ethnicity,
in its languages, in its musical
styles is forming a soundscape,
OK, a Moroccan soundscape.
So what do I mean by this?
Well, you know, we certainly
operate within a soundscape, right?
We were walking around Washington,
DC or New York City in my case and,
you know, there are sounds, there
are sounds going on there's a beat
to the city kind of, you know?
And I think that's an important part
of our feelings as human beings.
When we're in this particular
soundscape it's part of constructing
who we are, much like of
course the language, I mean,
this is an ethnomusicologist
rendition here very much.
So, if I'm, you know, tooling
around Washington, DC--
well, let's go a little
further south
into Richmond or something, right?
Obviously my dialect of English
is going to be colored by that
which I hear around me, and so
much is the same case with music,
which is around us and
is coming into our ears
and is becoming part of us.
So, in this particular case, in
the Moroccan setting we're talking
about a soundscape that is
extremely rich and diverse.
And one in which there are clearly
are no walls, but lots of moments
of blending and crossover
between communities.
So, if we can take ourselves for a
moment and imagine the unseen world,
which of course is the
world of sound, right,
it's unseen, it's just around us.
If we can take ourselves out of
the seen world, which includes,
you know, judging a book by its
cover, knowing who's different
from one another, knowing
the political stuff,
knowing all these kinds of
distinctions and rather envision
that there is this entire sphere of
human experience that's happening
without borders and
without any sort of control
over any ability to
even control, right?
Because you cannot box up
what is in that soundscape.
Then it becomes a field, if you
will, of contact of shared humanity
of intercultural relations that then
forms something that's even greater
and emergent once again from
these different parts, right?
So the sum being greater-- or the
whole being greater than the sum
of the parts kind of idea.
So that Moroccan soundscape
is sort of where I'm--
what I'm aiming at here and
then that Moroccan soundscape
as a reference point
or as an inspiration
for taking it into
the global sphere.
So let me share with you now
a little bit of recordings
from some of my favorites.
First is Amina Alaoui.
This is "Melhun," which
is a style sung in Arabic
that is including some
classical elements
but it's also very much a music
of the lay people in the city
and expressing a kind of intensity
of diversity that one would expect
in a cosmopolitan kind of center.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] The fact that
you have a woman singing, right,
and leading this is a very
significant part of this.
[ Music ]
I'm just going to see if this
might sound a little better.
If you don't mind,
bear with me a second.
Let's see.
[ Music ]
Let me just put this.
This composer, Salim
Halali, band leader, is--
had a club in Casablanca for
many years called Le Coq d'Or,
"The Golden--
>> Audience member: Rooster.
>> Samuel Thomas: -- Rooster".
Thank you.
And, so he's a Jewish leader but he
sings almost exclusively in Arabic
and this style would
be the cha'abi style.
OK. OK, this may-- oh, let's see.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] Sorry.
And he's active in the
1950s and '60s primarily.
[ Music ]
He himself is of Amazigh
background and that's significant
because of Amazigh
Jewish background.
[ Music ]
I was saying that he's actually
of Amazigh Jewish background,
which is often not thought about,
but again it's another example
of the intensity of this
diversity in Morocco that Amazigh
or the Berber community
has Jews and Muslims.
So, he's definitely
representative of that.
This is a bit of Gnaoua music.
And now what we'll
check out here is --
now we're going to start
to see the projection
of Moroccan musical culture
into the global sphere.
And this is certainly something
that is aided by modern technology
from recordings being
circulated throughout the world,
certainly the internet now
makes, you know, makes me be able
to visit a village in Morocco
while sitting in my bedroom--
YouTube and listening to some
music, which is quite cool.
But that circulation
technology certainly the advent
of modern travel technology
and communication technology
in general is creating an entire--
another realm for experiencing
Moroccan music as oppose
to maybe taking one individual
coming from another place
and introducing something
into another place,
there's much more robust
opportunity for sharing.
And this, as I've already
made the point,
is inherent to Moroccan
culture anyway this kind
of cross-intercultural confluence
going on in this nexus point,
so it's quite natural:
but let's take a listen
to some Gnaoua music from Morocco.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] And now for
Hassan Hakmoun, who is a performer
in New York City, and
you can hear the tabla,
the Indian tabla mixed in here.
[ Music ]
Lots of reverb effects and things
like that from electronic recording.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] This
is some Amazigh music,
traditional Amazigh music.
This is Mohammed Rouicha in the
Atlas Mountains, "Awa Awa Zin",
playing a lotar, a string
instrument with a skin resonator.
[ Music ]
And this is a Bendir drum,
a frame drum with snares,
very typical Moroccan drum,
also relative of the Pandero,
Bendir-- Pandero in Spain.
[ Music ]
Call-and-response elements
there in this music quite a lot.
Now this is a modern version,
this is Cheb i Sabbah, a remixer,
taking much of that same stuff
and now projecting this
into European context.
[ Music ]
Lots of electronic effects.
So, there are some
examples of this happening.
I'm going to invite up some
musicians now to join me and share
with you something from the
Arab-Andalusia tradition.
The piece that we're going to
listen to is, it's called a "Tushia"
and it is a kind of
a foundational piece
that sets the mode of the music.
Thank you for joining here in a bit.
Sorry we have to take that away
so we don't blind anybody, OK?
So, yeah, ready?
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
So, I'll introduce them now: this
is Eric Platz on the percussion,
John Murchison on the bass, and
Eylem Basaldi on the violin.
[ Applause ]
Let me have you move away because
they're going to turn that on again.
So the idea of the
Moroccan Diaspora,
certainly Diaspora is a concept
we're all familiar with and coming
from the Jewish experience,
the notion of a spread
from an individual-- from
a particular homeland,
having an orientation to that
homeland and in the case of the Jews
with the 2000-year-old
Diaspora the notion of an exile
or a schism causing
this spread to occur.
There has been a lot of
discussion in Diaspora studies
over the last couple decades
of extending that term now
in a more modern period
with globalization
and such transnationalism, what
have you, and that still scholars
of Diaspora studies agree
that there is some connection
over a large expense fostered,
these connections fostered
by cultural expressions
and in this case music.
So, the American context of Moroccan
musical life certainly include a
connection to this
Moroccan Diaspora,
which loosely would
include France and Canada
as two other particularly strong
nodes of Moroccan life, and Israel,
which has a large Moroccan
population.
So, the American context in New
York and in LA and even here
in the Washington DC
area certainly contribute
to this diasporic constellation,
as I like to think of it.
Now, my work is focused mostly on
the Moroccan Jews in Brooklyn, well,
around the world but, you know,
when you're doing a PhD dissertation
you have to pick a spot [laughs].
So I focused primarily here.
And in this community, the community
itself has roots from the 1950s.
As you see in this picture here
on the right, there were groups
of young men brought from Morocco
to study in Jewish seminaries
in Brooklyn, a couple
waves of young boys
who later would become
communal leaders
in the Brooklyn Middle Eastern
Sephardic Jewish community.
So this is many-- this is them
coming fresh off the boat here
to Israel-- I'm sorry, to America.
Here is a Moroccan synagogue in
Brooklyn, kind of the flagship,
I would say, Moroccan synagogue, the
synagogue where the representative
from the Moroccan consulate
comes every Yom Kippur
to receive a blessing for the
king of Morocco from the Rabbi.
And so the Rabbi invites him in and
opens the arc with the Torah scrolls
and gives a blessing to the
king of Morocco from Brooklyn.
So that notion-- yeah,
of connection.
And meanwhile I should point out,
that while this picture really
doesn't do a justice there is
so much hand carving-- hand
carved work all around the ceiling
that was provided by the previous
king, Hassan II, sending artisans,
a team of artisans from
Morocco to actually do this
for the Moroccan Jewish
community in Brooklyn.
This is the Rabbi of the
synagogue, Gad Bouskila,
and he is also the prayer leader
and does a lot of the chanting
of the sacred text as well.
Again, Jewish approaches in this
particular case to reiterating
that Moroccan soundscape idea,
so let me just play you a bit.
What I want to play you now is
actually a recording that I made
in the field in Morocco in
Shifshawan which is a town
in the north, which I had
the pleasure of visiting.
And I was woken up at, oh,
maybe 4 o'clock in the morning,
by the sound of this
muezzin chanting.
And the way Shifshawan is built,
it's quite hilly and there's,
you know, some differences there
and so right out the backside
of my first floor window of
the Riyadh that I was staying
in was the minaret speaker
from the mosque, so.
But, you know, it really brought,
it really drove home this idea
of the soundscapes, right?
And I was thinking to myself and
certainly in my professional work
as a musician I'm thinking about
this idea of the soundscapes
of Morocco and generating
some connection to that,
even in a new way by new
composition and such like that.
So, we're going to hear now
this soundscape in action, OK,
just imagine its 4 o'clock
in the morning, all right?
And then we'll follow that up
with hearing some sacred
text cantillation in Hebrew.
And I want you to just notice the
similarities, the musical modes,
the-- just the way
things are expressed
and that can drive home some of this
notion of that soundscape is just--
it's something that
belongs to everybody.
[ Music ]
And you can hear in the distance
another one happening as well.
[ Music ]
And this is in Hebrew.
So then we have the
Arabic and the Hebrew.
This cantillation bit that I
played you is actually a rendition
of different markings of
cantillations, you know,
of the Torah, so it wasn't actually
verses from the Torah per se,
but that would be exactly
how it would sound
than as applied to the Torah text.
So, another way of
constructing a Jewish iteration
of this Moroccan soundscape and
keeping it alive in this Diaspora is
through these contrafacta
techniques which is very popular
in the Jewish community: one is
Trakib and the other is non-Trakib.
Tarkib is a practice where the
actual Arabic is reinvented
in the Hebrew and there's an attempt
by the poet to match the phonetics
of the Arabic and the
syllables a well.
So for instance, there's a famous
[foreign language] text called
[foreign language].
All right, [foreign language], in
Hebrew becomes [foreign language].
So, that is very, very similar.
That's Tarkib.
Non-Tarkib is I will just
take the actual melody
and simply graph the
Hebrew text on it.
This is definitely common way of
bringing in the Moroccan sound
into the prayer services
in a Moroccan synagogue
by the cantor literally taking
something that would be common
and well known and just
applying whatever liturgical text
at that particular moment.
So, what I'd like to-- I'm going
to invite the musicians back up,--
-- play for you here just a moment
this "El Adon" and "Qum Tara,"
"El Adon" being the Hebrew;
"Qum Tara" being the Arabic.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] This is a cantor.
This is a field recording
of mine as well.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
I'll play just a couple more bits of
this kind of idea, and let you open
that cap up there for me.
So, here again is my cantor
friend whose name is Hiram Dehan
[assumed spelling].
[ Music ]
Now the Arabic, with an ensemble.
So, we're hearing it there I'm
going to play you a little bit more.
This is an Arabic rendition of
a piece called "Ana Maly Fiash"
which is performed by one
of the ensembles I lead
which is ensemble performing tonight
which is the New York
Andalus ensemble and this is
"Ana Maly Fiash," which is a Arabic
text drawing text from the Quran.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] That's her.
And now we'll hear the same melody,
slower, but used for the liturgical.
[ Music ]
[Background Music] And in this
case it's important to recognize
that the soundscape is
actually reiterated here
in a cappella version
in the synagogue.
[ Music ]
So, these are examples of
these-- oops, let me just move on.
This is from-- I have a
few more minutes, yeah?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
OK, OK good.
Let me-- I'm getting
to the wrap up here.
So this is a recording, a
field recording, as well,
of a piece of music
called "Ashira Na."
and this is going to-- is
used to celebrate Rabbi,
a Rabbi in Moroccan history
named Yaakov Abuhatzeira.
And we'll hear this is at a home
in Brooklyn, sung a cappella
and then we're going to
perform a little bit of it.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
And in sum, I would turn to the
Hebrew Table here and say that,
and I understand some
of you must exit at 1 --
so I'm going to just let
them leave for one second.
In sum this is what I
kind of I'm coming to:
which is that with
this Diaspora identity
which is not uniquely only
Jewish, but it's certainly
in the Jewish context is
another Jewish Diaspora,
one that is not the Jewish
Diaspora, but it's simply another.
So I called this the "Layered
Diaspora Consciousness"
as being formulated by these
different musical expressions
and so I'll just read this:
An additional Jewish ethnic identity
becomes truly diasporic only
when a robust consciousness
of another homeland,
in addition to ancient Israel,
as well as a sense of belonging
to another transnation in addition
to the transnational Jewish
community, are maintained
through cultural expressions
of the community.
Moroccan Jews in America
rely upon musical expressions
in the synagogue life
to construct dimensions
of what I call a Layered
Diaspora Consciousness.
Connoting the complex juxtaposition
of multiple Jewish diasporic
ethnic identities informing,
a Layered Diaspora Consciousness is
a term used to describe how members
of the American Moroccan
Jewish community use forms
of musical expression to reproduce,
reinterpret, and transmit traits
from three overlapping
yet distinctive diasporic
ethnic identities: Jewish,
Shephardi (Spanish),
and Maroka'i, Moroccan.
I envision this Layered Diaspora
Consciousness as an amalgamation
of different diasporic
ethnic identities
and these layers should not be
seen as hierarchical or nesting,
but rather they are
interacting rather than competing
with one another, a co-mingling
of Diaspora identities.
As a dynamic cultural expression,
music has a privileged role
in affecting this Layered
Diaspora Consciousness.
Music is a dynamic medium
that engages with the past
and present simultaneously,
and is used to convey
communal narrative histories
and negotiate communal
boundaries and cultural influences.
Musical expression has a
specialized role in the life
of the Moroccan American
Jewish community.
It is the preferred medium for
performing liturgical rites,
recitation of sacred texts, and
para-liturgies used in the home
and the synagogue, as well
as a fundamental element
in celebratory events.
And with that I say thank you.
[ Applause ]
And I think I have some
time for a few questions.
I do have time for a few
questions if anybody has.
Or, remarks.
Yes?
>>Female audience member:
I was wondering
if you are applying all these things
in the Christian community,
in the Church?
Are there similar kinds or
differences in Moroccan music,
to the extent that the
Church was a factor?
>> Samuel Thomas: The--
Are you referring to Christian
communities in Morocco?
>> Female audience
member: Yeah, yeah.
Morocco.
>> Samuel Thomas: Well,
the Christian community
is very, very small.
So, primarily isolated to some of
the Spanish provinces but, you know,
again, that soundscapes
idea is absolutely--
we could use the Coptic community
in Egypt as another example
or the Christian communities
of Iraq and the idea
of incorporating those sounds.
It's part of the sound
sphere for sure.
Yeah. Yes Sir?
>> Male audience member: The Spanish
or Iberian context you mentioned:
did that include Portugal
as well or strictly Spanish?
>>Samuel Thomas: Oh I would, I would
include Portugal as well, for sure,
especially in terms of the
historically when we're speaking
about Andalus or Andalusia
then we are talking
about the whole Southern
breadth of the Iberian Peninsula.
Yes ma'am?
>> Female audience member:
How if that all has the
French language be integrated
in more traditional
religious business in Morocco?
>> Samuel Thomas: Well, not so much
the-- well the language, French,
is definitely a preferred language
within the Jewish community
and I would say that the-- certainly
some songs that have been composed
in French, songs by such composers
like Enrico Macias, who is Algerian,
but he is borrowing nevertheless--
even Salim Halali wrote
a couple songs in French
but they are still borrowing and
they're really putting the French
into a Moroccan musical context.
And so then when the language is
changed to Hebrew it's really sounds
like a Moroccan musical song
as oppose to a French song
and certainly French languages
used in liturgy, so...
>> Female audience member: What
would you say is the prognosis
of continuing, you know,
the American Moroccan
Jewish musical tradition?
I mean, so I grew up
around here, I learned some
of the [inaudible]
Congregation, there are fewer
and fewer young people going and,
you know, learning Sephardic songs.
Most Jewish schools in American
follow an Ashkenazi a tradition.
What have you seen in
your studies of, you know,
longevity of this traditions?
>> Samuel Thomas: Well, that's a
great question and it's a question
that certainly brings
to light a challenge.
You know the American Jewish context
is often associated as one of bagels
and lox and that is
not the whole story
of the American Jewish community.
Certainly the American
Jewish community
and its foundations is Sephardic.
And in fact, you know, George
Washington, his understanding
of Jewish life would not have
included bagels and lox at all.
He would have certainly understood
it from the Sephardic perspective.
I do think that in this-- the
Moroccan Diaspora kind of idea
where there is such flows between
Morocco and Diaspora communities,
there are a lot of French
Moroccans Jews going back-and-forth
to Morocco.
There are certainly some
folks recently went from here
and there are people going
back-and-forth and that--
and the fact that there are
Moroccans-- not just Jewish--
living within communities
and engaging with Jews here.
I think the prognosis is that
the resources are there and the--
like I said before,
the ability to travel
and for communication
technologies and stuff are there.
What isn't there enough yet and --
is a consciousness that
needs to be developed.
I think, you know,
some of that has to do
with impulses towards
dissimilation when immigrating,
certainly second generation ideas.
And so I think that's where a
lot of the work needs to happen.
And if you do not just to say, like,
"let's learn some Sephardic songs,"
but more importantly to
learn what is really inherent
in Moroccan culture; that
informs Moroccan identity outside
of Morocco; and also
inherent in the relationship
between Morocco and America.
One that I think is special
and it's formed from early on.
Yes sir?
>> Male audience member: To
the extent that you know,
is there any part of
musical evolution that end
up in the United States from
people who were enslaved African
or Black people, whatever : enslaved
[by] Barbary pirates, et cetera,
because in the 17th century -has
anyone read anything about that?
>> Samuel Thomas: If you mean
from Morocco itself, you know,
there is not much of a slave trade
from Morocco into the Western world,
you know, it's all really
happening in Sub-Saharan--
West Africa and southward.
>> What I mean, I was Williamsburg
and they had a whole
tradition-they talked
about Moroccan Muslim slaves
ending up in Virginia so I don't--
>> Samuel Thomas: Yeah, I mean
that certainly-- and not that...
to answer your question,
no I don't know
if any research has been
focused on that yet.
Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Can you
do one more question?
>> Samuel Thomas: One more?
Sir Charles?
>> Sir Charles Jahant: You have
in front of you a beautiful lady
in green, who can sing every song
in every tone you can imagine.
She happened to be my cousin.
>> Samuel Thomas: OK [laughs].
Excellent.
So is there a question there?
Just a statement of fact, OK, so
let me take one last question.
Yes sir?
>> Male audience member: When
the Jewish people begin--
the younger Jewish people began
to arrive roughly in the 1950s--
what language did they
speak to each other?
And-- I guess two parts
to this question --
have they maintained that language?
And what has happened to the
Moroccans who moved to Israel?
Have they maintained the
languages that they were speaking
to each other in Morocco?
>> Samuel Thomas: And I want to
expand the notion of language
to include musical expression.
Language is just, you know, one
version of cultural expression.
And first of all, the flows
of Moroccan immigrants
to America have continued
over decades.
This particular beginning or
inception of the community
in Brooklyn was a specifically
isolated kind of event in context,
but in the '70s-- '60s and '70s
there are more folks coming
to America.
Now, the community at least in
America is really includes a lot
of Moroccans directly from
Morocco; Moroccans from Israel;
and Moroccans from France, so
they're kind of intermingling.
So in terms of languages, well, if
you ever visit a Moroccan synagogue
on a Saturday morning, you could
hear a French coming in this ear,
and Arabic maybe in this ear and
Hebrew in this ear and English
in this ear, you know, you
don't have enough ears to listen
to all the languages
that are spinning about.
So, I do think in terms
of keeping language
or keeping musical traditions
alive, the different kinds
of expressions are happening within
the community, which of course,
is centered around
the synagogue life
and therefore the liturgy reiterate
so much of this and the other kind
of para-liturgical traditions,
whether it'd be songs
at a wedding even or a
circumcision ceremony
or Haylula celebration are these
kinds of areas allow for this
to be continued and sort of
encoded over generations.
Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Thank you.
I want to thank Dr. Thomas
and the musicians for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Samuel Thomas: Thank you.
Thank you, Nancy.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.